hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited subscribers video as most
of you know somewhere before New Year's
maybe even before Christmas I requested
that you create a photo or a video of
yourself teaching someone how to play
chess I went to eat your father your
mother grandfather girlfriend boyfriend
brother sister really anyone and that
you send it to me to an email I had in
the description of probably all of my
videos so a lot of you have done this
some of you sent me photos of just
yourself some of you sent me a photo of
your dog but most of you sent me a photo
of you actually teaching someone how to
play chess some of you actually sent me
videos some of them were actually very
creative which you will see in this
video that will follow and ok some of
you sent me spyware some of you sent me
viruses but after I filtered all of it
out I managed to create this nice video
of your photos videos and your stories
so here it is I do hope you enjoy it
let's check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone this is my Azerbaijan
friend Vitaly and I teach him to play
chess too weak too slow
he thinks Kasparov is good what is this
sorcery Talas good anyways I do hope you
enjoy this video you can always check to
my ex-wives here and I will see you soon
[Music]
so that the video I do hope you enjoyed
it and I will leave this email in the
description of all of my videos you can
send me more of your own photos and
videos and after it piles up after I
will have enough to create another
subscribers video I will definitely do
so now another announcement I wanted to
make is about subscribers games in the
description of this video and every
other video I will make there will also
be an email where you will be able to
send me your own games they have to be
over the board games not games plain and
chest comedy chess chess 24 so I need
serious game serious games either for
raiding or tournament games basically so
there will be something to analyze if
it's just a game over over over the
Internet who knows maybe your opponent
is making french fries and he's not
really even looking at the board so
that's what I require the PGN of the
game and in the same format that I post
the pea Giants in the description of all
my videos about the games that I post so
please send me pigeons in that format
and also I require a photo of yourself
it would be nice if you had a photo of
your opponent although it's not really
necessary I can always use the hoodie
guy but it would be more professional
and you know maybe your opponent will
also watch this video so it would be
nice to have a photo of him as well a
couple of words about yourself upload
words about the game that was played
what tournament it was and well
basically anything you want to share
with the world if your game will be
shown so that's it about subscribers
games and one other thing a lot of
people ask me how come I don't have
patreon I do have patreon I made it like
three or four months ago I just never
published it the reason I never
published it was patreon works you have
to have like different ranks for patrons
and you have to have some prizes for
them and I I never really thought I
always wanted to make all of my content
available for everyone that's why that's
why I do accept contributions but I
don't have any special content for
people who contribute
so I will probably publish my patreon at
one point but I still have to figure out
how to do it as I don't really see any
making any special content for people
who who actually support me on patreon
so if I ever do it it will be more in
the style of those who are able and
willing to support me on patreon will be
supporting me so those who are not able
to support me for this or that reason
are also able to enjoy the content so
basically that's it I do hope you
enjoyed the subscribers video and these
few announcements as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]